oh hey you still play chess right yeah i
still dabble
you up for uh you up for like a friendly
game
friendly it's anything but friendly i'll
crush you oh man i'm so rusty but i'd
love to love to put you back in the poor
house i've memorized over 300 openings
and practice every day for the past year
you have no chance yeah no i'm pretty
trash too like i haven't played in a
while
king's gambit by far my best opening
especially if he accepts it alright joma
i accept your gambit
you've activated my trap card
little does he know this is my best
opening
first i play knight f3 then he responds
with g5 and then quickly h4 the pai
attack
what is this
you thought i'd play g5 didn't you it's
the wagenbach opening an unconventional
but dangerous opening much less study
than the classic variation
i don't mind a little variation in my
game it's time
[Music]
[Music]
his queen
what a blunder
victory is mine
rookie mistake i guess you haven't
improved
[Music]
check
check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you